by a moat of nine to three
my goal
from the Big Brother Canada house please
get your things and say your good-byes
[Music]
Michael second houseguest to leave the
BB kin eighth house so we just saw that
moment like the moment it happened what
went through your head a bit of a bit of
relief in a bit of you know obviously
you know bitterness like I I was just
disappointed a little bit that the house
couldn't kind of rally up and you know
supporting against a bigger threat and
you know I think just Brook and I
stacked up I was one of the people that
could you know remain the target in the
house and really fight back kind of
thing and so but sadly people were
scared they just wanted to you know go
with the house up until that point did
you believe that you had the numbers and
who do you think flipped so I can narrow
down to like you know three three or
four people so I got Jamar Angie Carol
and here are they they were all people
that individually told me that I had
their votes like I got and so I knew I
told them I'm like it remains up to you
guys whether I stay in this house and
because they weren't on any either side
of the house but they were just scared
of really shaking things up and so they
were more worried about their own safety
yeah and so sadly people sacrifice you
know short term gain versus long term
gain yeah yeah now we know that you
value loyalty and integrity so what what
did you learn about those things in the
Big Brother house versus what your
experience is with those things in the
real world
definitely yeah so I was trying to
instill like as much of my values in the
people in the house that I could because
you know I know that was gonna take him
far at the end I got to keep the people
closest to you that you trust the most
and that you feel loyal to because
really those are gonna be with you at
the end of the day and you know in the
house you know trust and loyalty is the
currency in the house like there's
nothing else that outweighs that and so
it's just too bad that people you know
couldn't see that and you know see the
the real threats in the house to him how
big of a surprise was that to you when
Chris put you up like it was about sixty
percent sure I was gonna be back doored
but you know I had the whole assurance
of the whole house that you know there's
a bigger plan at stake you know that it
wasn't gonna happen and so when it
happened I was like I knew as soon as
you started a speech I'm like you know
that's it for for Michael kind of thing
and so you know and Kyle was just so
good at having the whole house like
wrapped around his finger
he played the emotional strings right
off the get-go yeah and he just had the
jump on everyone and so he he was in
everyone's a year yeah it's no secret
about the relationship and the the
showmance and the hopefully outside of
showmance right between you and Matty
yeah if she makes it all the way through
she's gonna be in there for a long time
just here we've got an extended season
right do you really believe that that
will hold are you kind of are you
concerned that things might shift
because what people are talking about is
Cris and what you might not have seen in
terms of Vicki what they think has
ulterior motives were with regards to
Matty definitely so I had a hunch that
Kris had it out for me because of Maddie
you know because her and I got so close
off the bat so I told Maddie I'm like
you know you got a long game to play
ahead you know you you know you got to
really bear down and you might have to
be friends with people you don't want to
be friends with and so you know I told
her like I hope to god that you know
like we'll be able to interact you know
after this and so she gave me a little
something to hers and I gave her a
little my mind you know for set
interactions so told her I was like you
know make sure you don't forget about me
maybe I should have carved my name in
the wall or something before I left
I'm pretty sure that your memories gonna
be pretty strong in the house yeah I'm
hoping so
when you look at who's left I mean you
just said Kyle was able to you know
emotionally manipulate mm-hmm people who
do you think is strong in that house who
do you think is it has a good chance of
making it all the way through I think
depending on this next HOH if I'm really
hoping my board JL really pulls out a
win there because you know that could
really change the tides in the house
because leaving I really wanted to
expose Kyle for for who he is and and I
and I think I gave the house the chance
to see that so they got the ammo they
just got a they got to use it and so I'm
really hoping JL takes a win there or
even Maddie takes a win there to really
you know change the tides in the house
because people really start to see those
people you know for the game they're
playing yeah you kept your profession in
your back pocket I'm for abyss and let
everybody know what's up on the way out
the door how do you think that affected
them and how that you know they might
look at you now yeah I'm hoping that you
know that that gave them you know maybe
a little bit more respect towards me and
I'm hoping I just wanted to leave a
little bit more courage and everyone in
the house because you know there's a lot
of people that were under side
they didn't want to stick with their
beliefs and so I was hoping that you
know what I said would really you know
hammer in for them to really stay true
to themselves and and you know don't be
scared to stand up for what you believe
in and so I think at the looking back I
think maybe if I would have said you
know my profession my career people
would have it maybe more trust in me
more respect and you know really thought
that I could do some some good in the
house but you know it's too late for me
now and so you know I'm hoping I just
left a good improving the block I'm like
it was my relationship with Chris that I
didn't you know exploit a bit more and
so I think you know if I would have done
that and that's a huge part of the game
I think that was really my failure but
my pride just couldn't get I couldn't
bro down with them yes can do it yeah
it's hard sometimes it is yeah people
look at you guys as alphas yeah yeah
yeah yeah and honestly I think some
people thought oh this is this would be
a good Coalition yeah yeah but but for
yeah for me I think you know when it
solidified for Maddy and I like he
really just you know I was his biggest
target and you know and for most part I
was Kyle's biggest target so it's
flattering to me that both those guys
you know they're today in a way but yeah
I definitely think he was a little bit
chilled over Maddy
so how much of this are you gonna be
following from here on out how much of
the show you're gonna be watching I
definitely there's gonna be that you
know sinking suspicion in the back of my
head but I just feel so bad I had to
leave you know Maddy John Luke and rien
behind because you know I hope the house
really sees them that they're good loyal
people and they're great to work with
and so I don't want them turning on them
for leave so I'll be sad I can't help
him you know yeah so I'd definitely be
staying in tune and especially if Jill
wins that HOH yesterday so I'm sure the
fancy we're gonna want to hear your take
on everything that's going on definitely
because they'll have that insider
perspective and it you know I know
I would think it was so far I was right
about everyone in the house so yeah well
doesn't have some insight let's see how
right you are moving forward yeah way to
go and what you were able to accomplish
in the first day Wow yeah and I can't
wait to hear what you had to say about
the rest of season thank you very much
girls thanks for having me